we have all these kind of um arguments
about how we avert the the Perfection of
AI from uh plausible sentence generator
into a paperclip maximizing super
intelligence but we don't talk about
what do we do about the decision support
systems that decide who's uh entitled to
benefits whose children get taken away
by Child Protective Services who's
entitled to uh subsidize housing who's
entitled to cash bail where the police
should deploy and and uh police people
whose face
matches a profile of faces that are
considered
[Music]
suspicious Cory drro welcome back to how
the light gets in thank you very much
it's a pleasure to be back fantastic so
you've obviously had this immensely long
and successful career as a science
fiction author and your most recent book
red team Blues also centers around
modern technology and I guess my first
question I wanted to ask is how did you
manage to kind of integrate these really
really Advanced technological Concepts
in a way that's really accessible to
readers but it's also integral to the
plot of the of the book well I I think
that that's kind of my uh my my my deal
is figuring out how to make science
fiction plots where the actual
limitations and capabilities of
Technology are the Crux of the plot
rather than an inconvenience to be
maneuvered around you know there's a
kind of techno Thriller where
there's just a kind of like insert
nonsense here way to set up problems for
the characters where we have to crack
the main frame and breaking the
encryption takes 11 minutes but we've
only got 10 minutes we're just going to
have to nerd harder uh and you know I I
think that um there just comes a point
where it lacks ver similitude and
salience uh it's a bit like going to
watch a western and maybe you don't
count how many bullets the six gun fires
but at the point where the horse starts
flying you're like I don't think horses
can do that uh so I've been involved in
Tech policy fights for uh 20 some years
and uh I've been a blogger for just as
long and blogging is this process
whereby everything that seems like it is
part of a bigger story even if you don't
know where it fits in you write up
whatever it was that caught your
attention for an audience of notional
strangers and uh and and in so doing you
fix it in your own memory and you
clarify it for yourself and you end up
with a kind of just like a a Big Raft of
facts and oddments at your disposal a
kind of super saturated solution of
fragments of ideas that are perennially
like nucleating and crystallizing and
then you also have the blog itself which
is a literal database that you can
search to find out what you what you
previously had thought about some
subject so this novel it's a
cryptocurrency heist novel it draws very
heavily on the critiques of
cryptocurrency that uh I and others have
been involved with for a couple of years
those um fights have been very bruising
a lot of the people involved in
cryptocurrency um say things that rhyme
with the things that I care about
decentralization uh
anti-authoritarianism
uh resistance to
censorship um but the mechanism whereby
they hope to attain it I find both
economically and technologically
incoherent and having those arguments
with people I often agree with has been
really something um uh it's one thing to
win an argument with someone you you
dislike but winning an argument with
someone you like is actually no fun at
all I also Drew on some um technical
ideas that I've been working with for
now more than 20 years the idea about uh
something called remote out a station
which is when your computer can tell
third parties who don't trust you what
it's doing in such a way that they trust
what the computer is saying so like
maybe you and a friend want to play a
video game and you want to uh assure
them that you're not running a cheat on
your computer uh remote at a station
would allow your computer to do this uh
it's also a way that if you rent Cloud
space in a server you can ask the server
how it's configured and make sure that
the people who run it aren't spying on
you or or sabotaging your work but it's
also a way that like your boss can make
you run surveillance Weare on your
computer in a way that's very hard for
you to defeat
without them knowing about it it's a way
that say the government of Iran could
insist that every computer in the
country be equipped so that it can know
how it's configured and this is
something that I've been quite alarmed
about for 20 years but is like so
esoteric and weird that it's very hard
to get other people to care about it and
you know Bruce Sterling when he reviewed
my novel walkway he said a lot of my
fiction consists of me building up and
demolishing arguments that no one except
me is ever Advanced and I think that
that's what I'm doing in this book and
to the extent that I'm I'm making these
Concepts more
accessible than they have been
historically or that I've managed
historically some of that I think is
down to us being in a world in which
these comp sets are a little more
familiar like we all know that our
iPhones are designed to stop us from
installing software that we want if
Apple doesn't want us to have it and so
we've got the sense that we have devices
that are loyal to someone other than
their owners but also with practice
comes Perfection that you know having
made these arguments now for 20 years
and having confronted the blank stairs
of people who I've left behind me as I
raced ahead of them you know talking a
spitt Fleck mile a minute uh I've I've
I've identified the weak spots and
shored them up somewhat and then when
you package them in fiction and you make
them the Crux of a a story about a
likable character trying to solve a
relatable problem uh I think it it it it
you know propels this explanation in a
way that it wouldn't if it were just a
technical explanation what people are
being presented with and what you're
sort of championing it doesn't seem like
an immediate threat and it's also you
have to sort of toy up in a way that
could kind of utilitarian aspect of I'm
being provided this service and really I
I'm I'm not mandated to kind of critique
it because you know I don't care if I'm
being spyed on I've got nothing to hide
but then that notion is is really really
worrying I wanted to talk a little bit
uh specifically about the character
Marty Hench and I wanted to ask sort of
how you managed to develop this Unique
Kind of blend of traditional kind of
Thriller hero character but obviously
with these sort of 21st century skills
how you go about the process of kind of
melding those two together sure yeah so
Marty hench's a 67-year-old forensic
accountant who's been in Silicon Valley
for 40 years unwinding the most
eye-watering Baroque Finance bro scams
that you can imagine he's seen it all
and he's ready to retire and has he gets
you know called out for one last job as
the Trope goes and um you know in the
Trad traditional Noir Thriller uh the
hero is a cop who will do things the
cops can't do right they'll break into
the warehouse and find the things that
you can't find because you can't get a
warrant they'll slap around the suspect
in a way that the cops couldn't and so
on and and by the time you get to the
end of the book one of the things that
is the motif of of the the the
hardboiled private eye is his
realization that a lot of the things
that the cops supposedly couldn't do
were actually things they wouldn't do
that the cops just weren't all that
interested in rud out corruption you
know it's Chinatown Jake and and Marty
is a different kind of cop he's he's a
revenuer he's uh he's he's basically an
unlicensed IRS agent and he's going
through the same realizations someone
called this book uh Panama papers fanfic
and uh you know when you read the Panama
papers and you read the really excellent
coverage that that came out of those
that that leak and Paradise papers and
propublica's IRS files and so on one of
the things that becomes very clear is
that these um supposedly genius things
that these enablers come up with for
offshore billionaires to duck their
taxes are really just sort of
performatively complex that that there's
not a lot of there there that they're
not hard to understand because they're
complex they're complex so they'll be
hard to understand and a lot of it is
just like doing the same thing over and
over again in a loop like okay we took
your money and we put it in a Scottish
trust and then we made the Scottish
trusts officers number companies in
gurny and then we made the officers of
the numbered companies in gy new
Scottish trusts and you look at this and
you're like so if you're not convinced
that just having the money in a Scottish
trust is secure because someone can
Piece the Veil of Pierce the Veil of
anonymity there so you've put them
inside gy numbered companies and you
think gery secrecy will protect you what
is putting the gery companies inside
Scottish trust at you didn't we say two
steps ago that we don't think Scottish
trusts are themselves robust enough and
and you know the conclusion that I end
up reaching is on the one hand someone
who's arranging these Affairs for Rich
monsters is just jacking up their
Billings but on the other hand that the
revenue doesn't give a right like
they that they all they want is
plausible deniability and you know we've
had all this um fuss over the last
couple of years about defunding the
police and how this is such a terrible
idea you know we defunded the police 40
years ago with Margaret Thatcher we
defunded the people who inspect
workplaces to see if they're safe who
inspect uh the the tail end of exhaust
pipes and the Smoke Stacks to make sure
that they're not murdering us we
defunded the police that make sure rich
people aren't aren't uh cheating on
their taxes like we defunded all the
police that matter you know there
there's far more wage theft than
burglaries uh both in total monetary
figures and in frequency those cops
aren't on the beat and haven't been uh
and you know the the ones who are left
are the kind of demoralized weak sister
cops that are the the the Trope of every
uh C boil detective novel where the the
detective meets the cop who's like well
what do you expect me to do and they
turn their nose up and they go I'm going
to go and solve this crime and that's
that's who Marty Hench is he's he's the
67-year-old forensic accountant who's
seen it all and understands that the IRS
is not doing its job not because uh they
can't but because they won't I wanted to
go back to the point you made um sort of
about obfuscation being this kind of
tactic of we'll make it as complex as
possible and then it will people will
sort of give up in light of it and it's
the same kind of when you're offered
sort of the same tactics with these Tech
monopolies and terms and conditions will
sort of bury them in
complexity and you're sort of up against
this
monolith you argued kind of in choke
point capitalism that we've kind of
entered this uh New Era of exploitative
business practices how much of it is
exploitative business practices and how
much of it is it just ineffective
antitrust
regulation well I think that you can't
separate Market concentration from Bad
regulation so you can think about
regulation as being like a kind of Truth
seeking exercise like we want to know
you know is it okay to put raw sewage in
the in the in the water right this is a
an actual question that we need to know
the answer to and it has a factual basis
and if the people who are interested in
dumping raw sewage in the water uh are a
big diverse sector with hundreds of
firms none of which Dominate and the
regulator convenes a uh truth seeking
exercise they put out in the United
States it would be a notice of inquiry a
notice of rulle making here it would be
a similar kind of inquiry from a
Ministry and they say please send us
your submissions and tell us what you
think um you would get a diversity of
replies and you would get replies to the
replies you would get people saying you
know this this company says it's fine to
have turds in the drinking water nothing
bad's going to happen let us tell you
why our company's solution is better we
are we we have far fewer turds in the
drinking water and and and and you
should be favoring our processes over
our competitors but when a sector
dwindles to four or five giant firms
they solve the collective action problem
of not arguing in front of the referee
right that all those arguments take
place in the Smoke field room beforehand
they Converge on a set of of priorities
and then they all show up and talk with
the same voice and yes academics and
activists and so on they speak uh as
well but you know the rebuttal to them
is like how many water systems are you
running
right and you don't know what you're
talking about you see this a lot with
network neutrality where you have all
the telecoms uh people come together and
say actually what people really want is
for their internet service provider to
deliver the bits that the isp's
shareholders would prefer you to have
asked for rather than the ones that you
actually want and this is there's some
sort of revealed preference where people
actually prefer this you get it a lot in
privacy right why would people sign away
their privacy if they didn't um uh not
value their privacy right uh and and you
know there are some pretty easy rebuttal
like apple added a oneclick opt out of
uh surveillance on on iOS devices 96% of
Apple users click that box the other 4%
presumably either worked for Facebook or
were confused right but even so
Regulators have a hard time building up
the evidentiary basis and so the failure
to to enforce competition law to to
block mergers uh to block predatory
conduct like predatory pricing you know
Uber lit lit $30 billion of Saudi oil
money on fire over 12 years in order to
drive taxi businesses out of business
stall public transit and create the
illusion that you could pay drivers uh
enough money to lure them out of other
forms of employment and yet charge
Riders so little that they would prefer
to ride in these cars losing 41 cents on
every dollar that they brought in for
more than a decade and so I think it's
dead in the water
um there's new legislation before
Parliament to give the long overdue
secondary enforcement powers to the
digital markets unit so under the
coalition government uh there was
legislation passed to Charter the
largest technical unit of any
competition regulator in the world
underneath the competition markets
Authority it's called the dmu 70
full-time Engineers on the public
payroll but they never passed the
secondary legislation giving them
enforcement Powers so for years this
group of very talented very smart
Engineers have been pulling apart these
Baroque scams like the adtech market the
mobile market and so on and writing
these bangers of reports like 400 Page
Long extremely readable very good
reports unwinding these scams you know
there's a a term in finance Migo which
stands for my eyes glaze over and it's
when you sort of wrap things in so much
complexity that people assume that
they're substantive like a pile of
big enough has to have a pony underneath
it and these guys are just just
shredding it now without enforcement
Powers there wasn't much they could do
here the European Union on the other
hand has h a real uh Poverty of
Engineers but a lot of enforcement
Powers so they've been running with it
but now we have uh legislation before
Parliament that um not only gives them
these enforcement Powers but actually
gives them the power to craft bespoke
remedies for each sector and firm so
they can go in and they can say like the
specific kind of that is Mark
Zucker bergian needs this remedy
and it's not the same thing we need for
Google and it's not the same thing we
need for Snapchat or Oracle and so they
can draft effectively full-blown
regulation for each of these firms to
curb their most abusive conduct so it's
quite exciting there is a moment all
over the world for this stuff uh you
know they say Stein's law is uh anything
that can't go on forever eventually
stops and there is a real sense that we
are at the end stage of how uh badly
we're prepared to allow for firms to
conduct themselves and that people of
all Stripes really want them to to pull
up their socks it does feel like we've
had a sort of damine moment and people
have most people have become aware that
there are these practices that are
undercutting them as a consumer and
you've been an integral part of that in
this way that you you bring what is
highly complex highly technologically
complex um issues to Light Within
science fiction and you appr them in a
way that doesn't feel dactic and how I
just wanted to try and understand how
you sort of present these things in a
way that doesn't feel I'm sort of
ramming this down your throat because
people need to be reawakened because
these are things that are happening now
yeah so I this is back to this idea that
you can approach the technical aspects
of a storyline as inconveniences to work
around or as parameters to build the the
plot out of right and so you know there
is a kind of heist story that goes first
we design The Heist and then we figure
out what they're stealing yeah uh and
then there's the other kind that's like
first we figure out something
interesting to steal and then we work
backwards and and make the heist up
which is how you would do it in an
actual Heist this is why you know the
hat and garden uh uh robbers are so
interesting right or the the there was a
a group of uh French um robbers who
during a uh one of their many many many
bank holidays uh tunneled into um a bank
vault and cleaned out all the safe
deposit box
and they there was evidence that they
brought along a Gourmet Chef and they
set up a canteen and they ate
spectacular meals and sort of were very
French about it we we all like these
these Caper stories because they
um they turn on something that is real
and interesting as opposed to something
that is a contrivance and a hypothetical
and so uh you know in in red team Blues
Marty Hench has to recover the missing
cryptographic keys for an wisely
inserted back door in a cryptocurrency
blockchain that will allow you to steal
all the money in the blockchain and uh
he um uh actually manages to recover the
keys but uh the people who stole them
turn out to be gangsters who wanted to
do money laundering uh who were double
crossing another group of gangsters who
wanted to do money laundering and they
both get angry at him and so now he has
to survive and you know the idea that
gangsters who do moneya laundering are
incredibly violent and vicious is not uh
a a thing that is you you have to reach
to very far to to uh believe in uh nor
that cryptocurrency's main use is to
dress up money laundering and
respectable clothes and pretend that
it's just uh fintech you know whenever
you hear fintech think unlicensed Bank
we've also now had this sort of
realization that cryptocurrency has been
duded of its kind of status of this sort
of um solution to obviously the
decentralization aspect was a really
really big kind of plus towards it it's
now fallen massively out of favor I
would say do you think that it's sort of
been successful from from pulling it
from this sort of revered status in
society yeah I mean I think that you
know this idea that um uh you don't
understand it but it's the next big
thing and if you don't get involved
you're going to you're going to miss out
uh as the as the Crypt Bros had it have
fun being poor uh has in large part uh
drawn down I think that there were some
people who are very susceptible to that
rhetoric in the same way that there are
some people who go and and uh pull lever
on a fruit machine and just can't stop
and those people are continuing to pump
real money into this funny money system
but I think a lot of the people involved
have pivoted to saying AI is the next
thing going to say and you know if
you're not in AI you're going to miss
out because eventually if the chatbot
makes sentences that are plausible
enough it will become a super
intelligence something something
something profit so and so you think
it's an unfounded move because obviously
they're drastically different sure and
there was this big joke that all of the
crypto Bros have now transformed
overnight into AI Bros they are
drastically different and I guess with
artificial intelligence you don't see it
as any kind of meaningful threat in the
same sense or oh I think like our bosses
want to fire our asses and replace us
with software like let's let's not you
know have any doubt about that when
Morgan Stanley says this is a $6
trillion doll opportunity what they mean
is we're going to put $6 trillion worth
the workers on the bread line but our
bosses don't give a
if the thing that they replace us with
works all they care is whether it's
profitable so think of every interactive
voice resp response system that replaced
a human operator that you've called and
said 17 no 17 17 17 Operator Operator
Operator so all they care about is that
there's no competition that a customer
can defect to if they're angry about the
fact that some automation has been moved
in that in shid ified the service to the
point where it's it's not worth using
anymore but it's the only game in town
that's the that's the goal here right
it's it's basically think of it as being
like um the shops and services oper
offered on the other side of the
security checkpoint at an airport they
don't have to be good because they're
the only thing going right and and you
know if you're stuck in a 16 hour
layover because the airline has decided
to cut its pilot uh Staffing levels to
the Bone and someone got a cold and now
the entire thing has been thrown into a
state of higgledy piggley you've got 17
hours and you're just going to be buying
11b bottles of water and giant bags of
dairy milk and whatever at at farcically
inflated prices because what else are
you going to do there's there's an old
famous Lily Tomlin sketch where she
plays a telephone operator and she uh
turns to the camera and says we don't
have to care we're the phone company
right and and that's that's the goal
here so you know when you see um uh
Hollywood exact saying effectively we
want to fire all the screenwriters and
replace them with plausible senten
generators that's because even if the
plausible sentence generators aren't
very good they have this weird hubristic
faith in their ability to through
iteration replace the um the
screenwriter who wrote good dialogue
with um their own kind of wild ass ideas
and and you know the the screenwriter's
experience of getting notes from an
executive is already just AI prompting
right like I need you to write me a
version of Indiana Jones but in space
and could you make it a horror movie but
make the hero a 10-year-old girl right
that is you know your classic like
executive to writer note and then the
writer makes it and they go can you
bring in a lovable animal in act two
this is just prompting right this is
just like write me instructions for
removing a grilled cheese sandwich from
a VCR in the style of the King James
Bible right it's just it's just
prompting and so you know what you get
with automation
is not something that's good but
something that doesn't complain when you
try to impose your Genius on it and it's
you know it's ever been thus right we we
have this uh liel that the Lites were
anti- technology and they were anything
but right to be a skilled uh textile
trades person in the early 19th century
you needed to do a seven-year
apprenticeship this is the equivalent of
getting a master's degree in engineering
from MIT right and their bosses built
machines that made very low quality
textiles but were so easy that children
could use them and the point was that
they could kidnap children from uh
Napoleonic War orphanages in London
indenture them to 10 years of service in
the dark satanic Mills of Manchester
maim them starve them mutilate them and
kill them in the teeth of the machine
and make gigantic profits without uh
having to do any kind of bargaining with
their existing Workforce and throw the
workforce on the on the rubbish heap of
history that was what the Lites objected
to right to call the Lites anti machine
is like calling Osama Bin Laden anti-
Aviation right they said like the thing
they were angry about was not the
machines you know there was a guy called
Robert blinko who was indentured for 10
years and nearly killed and watched lots
of other children killed and he wrote A
Memoir when he finally escaped the
factory which was a national bestseller
and inspired Dickens to write Oliver
Twist like Oliver Twist was a thinly
veiled documentary about working
conditions uh that and specifically the
working conditions the lot we're angry
about this replacement of Highly skilled
labor with something that's sort of
permissible scalable on mass it's the
same with something like chat GPT yeah
and in a way it's this sort of deferring
of kind of this conscious awareness of a
human being engaging in something more
and more of our society is becoming sort
of underwritten by what's what's
basically machine intelligence in that
sense yeah I mean so this is the you
know when we talking before about like
um people giving warnings about
technology and not being heated you know
one of the one of the complications
about this is that um often times the
warnings are self-serving nonsense right
so you know Facebook declared themselves
to be evil Sorcerers who'd figured out
how to hack our dopamine Loops when they
were really just monopolists who uh were
stealing from Publishers and advertisers
by just flooding The Zone with
uh but you know they liked the idea that
um you know Robert Mercer was using
their mind control rate to make your
uncle into a qinon uh when your uncle
was really just a racist gamon all along
and uh you know by taking credit for
this they could go to the advertisers
who said why should we pay a 40% premium
to advertise on Facebook and they could
say haven't you heard I'm an evil
sorcerer who hacks dopamine Loops you
know you're racist Uncle that was me
right and so you know a lot of These
Warnings like we get warnings about AI
that are like AI is going to become
super intelligent and then it's going to
decide to turn the world into paperclips
and we're all going to be deconstructed
and reassembled as paperclips by the
paperclip maximizing machine and
meanwhile so we have all these kind of
um arguments about how we avert the the
Perfection of AI from a plausible
sentence generator into a paperclip
maximizing super intelligent
but we don't talk about what do we do
about the decision support systems that
decide who's uh entitled to benefits
whose children get taken away by Child
Protective Services who's entitled to uh
subsidize housing who's entitled to cash
bail where the police should deploy and
and uh police people whose face matches
a profile of faces that are considered
suspicious we're already kind of facing
these problems today we are sort of
seeing how certain system systems
produce certain outcomes that don't
really benefit certain groups in any
meaningful sense but we have this
inability to sort of work out where it
went wrong I think that it's because uh
certain uh explanations are out of scope
so we think about things like the
housing crisis right we we um ask
ourselves how can we solve the housing
crisis without building more public
housing and uh so we come up with all
these ways to sort of lure the animal
Sentiments of the market into building
more housing we we um you know say like
more fireproof more more uh highly
flammable cladding might do it or we say
um you know tax breaks for people who
buy the let might do it or maybe we give
people help to buy and drive up the
price of every flat or you know maybe if
we put five shows on the BBC in which
people buy and flip houses somehow that
will conjure more housing into being and
because we're not allowed to say like
what if we just built more houses
in the same way that you know whenever
we talk about unsustainable wages we
always talk about training we don't talk
about minimum wages and um there's this
kind of story that minimum wages crowd
out uh jobs and they they prevent jobs
from being created and zero contracts
create the flexibility to create jobs
none of this Bears empirical scrutiny
but it's so doctrinally ingrained that
we're not allowed to to ever consider
and so we're left with the like why we
try this this other thing that is very
implausible instead of the obvious thing
that's why do you think we avoid the
obvious thing why don't you think
there's more people just saying flat out
well I think that we've had 40 years of
being told that um governments can't do
anything and markets can do everything
do you think that we're going against
this now I think people are starting to
see that markets just simply don't have
yeah I think anything that can't go on
eventually stops and in particular
Market's ability to regulate um uh the
climate impacts of industrial production
which are
literally driving us to the brink of
Extinction have made people lose
confidence and every time we try to add
markets right say carbon offsets we we
create what economists call the market
for lemons where uh the carbon offsets
that are the lowest quality and do the
least to mitigate harm are the cheapest
to make and therefore become the ones
that markets prefer and so we end up
with all of the carbon offsets just
being nonsense right being things like
The Nature Conservancy buying for us
that are already protected preserves and
ineligible for logging and then signing
a declaration saying we'll never log
this force that we were already not
allowed to to log and then minting a
carbon offset and then when the forest
burns down in a wildfire that carbon
offset continues to circulate in the
market even though the forest doesn't
even exist anymore and whenever we see
this we're like well I guess you know uh
we need to try harder to make our carbon
offsets more high quality but at a
certain point we're like actually the
problem is that the carbon offsets
themselves just don't work maybe we need
to just directly regulate what sort of
things we can do and you know honestly
like we are surrounded by the evidence
of our capacity as a species to make
good regulation right there are no
microbiologists in Parliament and yet
you don't die of leria every time you
drink your tap water although we're
headed that direction right and we're
not headed that direction because the
microbiologists who used to be in
Parliament lost their seats right we're
ahead of that direction because we've
allowed Market concentration to distort
our capacity to make regulation but
making good water regulation it's not
like embalming pharaohs right it's a
thing like there are people alive today
who remember how we did it we could do
it again we just need to um curb that uh
Market concentration that that makes it
impossible to make good rules so a good
recent example of this is um what
happened when David nut was the the are
uh the drug are um so in the UK two
companies control all the beer and two
companies control all the spirits he
wrote a paper in which he said that uh
cannabis was less harmful than alcohol
which is a empirical fact alcohol is an
extremely dangerous drug and um Jackie
Smith uh rang him up and said uh you
can't do this uh she was the Home
Secretary you can't do this you can't
compare alcohol to Canabis and he said
well why not and she said well because
cannabis is illegal and she said why is
and he said well why is it illegal and
she said because it's harmful he said
but it's not as harmful as alcohol she
said but you can't compare alcohol to
cannabis and he said why not she said
well because cannabis is illegal right
this circular reasoning goes around and
around meanwhile the drinks industry in
their own internal Communications admits
that um all of their profit all of their
margin comes from selling alcohol to
binge drinkers right to people who drink
unhealthily they claim that they regret
this fact and so they have uh
self-regulated curriculum to try to
discourage people from B binge drinking
which is wildly ineffective and when
they're confronted with this fact they
say the reason it's wildly ineffective
is because it's impossible to convince
people not to binge drink so David nut
wrote a curriculum to discourage binge
drinking and went and delivered it uh in
a kind of randomized trial and
determined that his curriculum worked
and their curriculum did the person who
wanted to make good regulation was
forced out right and so we can see that
repeated in so many domains and I think
increasingly people are just um
unwilling to say that the answer to the
machine is the machine that if
capitalism isn't working we need more
capitalism that we just haven't made the
market free enough for it to clear and
produce these optimal
outcomes what will your next book be
about so my next book I write when I'm
anxious I have six more books in
production uh my next book is coming
from Verso in September it's uh it's
called the internet con uh how to seize
the means of computation and it's a big
Tech disassembly manual it's a set of
detailed policy prescriptions for
getting rid of big Tech then I've got a
novel in November called um the lost
cause that's a post Green New Deal novel
uh about uh uh Counter Reformation
against uh uh a movement to really help
the climate and and do something about
it composed of white nationalist
militias and uh aarco capitalist
seagoing Wreckers living on uh a fleet
of um of renovated aircraft carriers and
then the next book is the sequel to uh
to Red Team Blues it's called the bezel
it's about prison Tech and it comes out
in February uh and then I've got a a
graphic novel for middle-grades readers
based on my Nolla unauthorized bread and
then a uh um uh short Story collection
collection of little brother short
stories and then the third Martin Hench
novel which is called picks and shovels
thank you very much thank you so
much for more debate talks and
interviews subscribe today to The
Institute of Art and ideas at II
TV